all right we start with uh actually some
movie news from deadline and there might
be more important things happening in
the country but i just thought that this
was uh here's here's some actual good
news something a little a little
something that we can celebrate uh and
this is deadline this is how this is
obviously a left-wing rag and uh this is
how they report on this
they say blame the fact that it doesn't
appeal to girls blame disney plus for
stealing family movie goers blame the
lack of an ensemble
toy story cast
heck blame everything as disney pixar's
light year didn't do its magic by
internal studio or industry standards
this weekend with 51 million dollars
close to a third below its 70 million
pre-release projection
it says this is an opening more in the
vicinity of pixar's original fare
so it could still lag out to 200 million
however given how this ip was built on
the back of the toy story brand it's
clear many were expecting significantly
more
light year overall was down in its
global start um
85.6 million versus the top 135 million
estimate we reported
so
and it was beat by jurassic world at the
at the box office and uh the long and
short of it is that this new toy story
movie this uh this offshoot
um light year which again is
this was a film
about
the backstory of the of the toy buzz
lightyear in in the world in the toy
story world
and it's doing incredibly poorly at the
box office uh way below projections it's
basically a box office dud now
you know for a lot of other movies 51
million dollars would not be anything
close to a dud but given that this is
toy story it's part of the franchise
it's disney all of the marketing
and media and press that went into this
51 million dollars is pathetic
and if you look at some of the headlines
in entertainment media today a lot of a
lot of the headlines like this and
deadline um they're all trying to figure
out what the heck went wrong how could
this have happened
this is a this is a toy story brand
movie that they're supposed supposed to
do 100 million dollars what's going on
it's a mystery
who could possibly explain this
well it's actually not a mystery at all
um i think there are
a couple of potential explanations here
not potential but
you know absolute
one of them is before we get to the
political part of it one of them is
actually that i think um
there reaches a point
where even the standard moviegoer
with his famously low standards
um
is
just kind of sick and tired of the same
old thing
just the same thing over and over and
over again you're just trying to shovel
the same
garbage into his mouth over and over and
over again
making a franchise out of everything
like the first toy story movie was just
it was a it was a cute little movie
about toys that come to life
and that was what 20 years ago
and 20 years later they're still making
these same things over and over again
so i think there's a there's some
exhaustion there on the movie going on
the part of the movie going public as
well there should be
but even more than that
is the fact
that this is
the woke toy story
and that's how it was advertised
and that's the that's what the press was
saying
that's the media attention it was
getting
and people don't want that
now
i haven't watched the movie i'm not
gonna watch it
as far as i know the only uh woke part
of the film is that they put this
lesbian kiss scene in there between two
characters i don't know if they're toys
or not well you know these are real
people in the in the toy store universe
so these are like real people but
cartoons okay so they're not toys but
there's a lesbian kiss scene
and the media has made uh
much ado about that
in a positive way they're celebrating it
and we know that disney they put that
lesbian kiss scene
in because or they put it back and
originally they had it in the story they
took it out because they figured it
didn't really help the story move along
they needed to cut it for time they put
it back in after
the anti-grooming laws in florida as a
political statement
and
the movie going public wants nothing to
do with that
you know lots of parents they don't want
to bring their kids to a cartoon movie
where there's a lesbian kiss scene
and they also don't want um
entertainment that has a political or
ideological message
they're just sick and tired of it
now
on hollywood's part they can complain
about that and say that oh we should
have an unending
insatiable appetite for this kind of
thing
should want this content in all of our
movies if we were truly virtuous people
well
i disagree with that but even if it was
true it's too bad people don't want it
they especially don't want it from their
kids entertainment
okay there's not a lot of parents out
there who want to take their kids to a
movie
and then
leave the movie
and that movie is now an opportunity to
have a discussion about lgbt issues
there aren't very many parents who are
looking for that from their
entertainment
so that's why it didn't do well
which is why i would say to hollywood
continue continue doing this all you
want because it's just uh it's just
total self-destruction
you're making yourself
more and more irrelevant
as i've said before i think that you can
find kind of a parallel this is sort of
the bizarro world version
of what christian
entertainment has done for so long
okay the difference is that with you
know so-called christian movies the
christian branded entertainment um they
put just like woke hollywood does now
they put the message before anything the
message is the most important thing the
difference is that with christian
entertainment the message is actually
good so that's that's the good part
but story comes second
plot writing
acting all these things are just after
thoughts
the actual entertainment quality of the
thing itself is an afterthought
and the idea among the christian people
in the inter christian entertainment
industry is that as long as the message
is there then sort of we've done our job
but you haven't really
because what you should be trying to do
is create great entertainment
that also has the positive message
which maybe means the message can be a
little bit more subtle
woke hollywood's doing the same thing
taking the message
only this time it's a bad message
and but the mistake they're making
strategically is they make the message
front and center
they especially did this with that with
this light year movie that's all of the
discussion about the light year movie
it was all about the lesbian kissing
nothing to do with the story
and they're paying the price for it
meanwhile and of course they're not
learning their lessons so star wars uh
we know that the
star wars franchise in general has gone
woke um has arguably been woke from the
beginning you might even say but uh
their twitter account in particular
is very woke so
they were responding over the weekend
to some random twitter user who said to
them don't make star wars political
and then the star wars account responded
and said
number one queer characters existing
isn't political number two star wars is
literally in our name
not exactly sure what they're going for
with point two but number one they say
queer characters existing isn't
political
well it is though and you've you've
decided that
so you use the quote-unquote queer
characters to make political points
that's exactly what disney did with with
the light year film
so no that's that's that's that's
exactly the case
you use these characters for to make
political statements
that was your decision not ours
people have noticed and they just want
no interest they have no interest in it
they want no part of it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts